this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by huel
in 1974 a group of scientists beamed a
message into space the message meant to
be received by an intelligent alien
species described live on earth written
in simple binary code and using the most
powerful radio telescope on the planet
the message was broadcast to a dense
cluster of stars in the constellation of
Hercules this exercise was just
ceremonial a way to demonstrate new
technology in radio astronomy nobody was
really expected to receive it and even
if they did it wouldn't be anytime soon
the nearest star in the direction of the
broadcast is 25 000 light years away so
if the telescope was tuned to 2380
megahertz aimed at Hercules and fired up
the scientists congratulated each other
shook hands and went on with their lives
but 27 years later something very
unexpected happened with that message
beamed into deep space
someone wrote back
[Music]
foreign
it is for me as well yes I'm starving
wait where are you and did you just call
me grasshopper grasshopper it has been
said that before asking too many
questions one must first learn the art
of listening now I have traveled to The
Shaolin Temple my uncle Irving watches
the show and he could tell I needed to
reset my
your uncle Irving oh yeah
oh yeah fine can I get back
[Music]
I just wanted
high protein low sugar plant-based meal
I know I was about to eat a bowl of
yellow coconut curry did
Buddha buddies hey ain't no better buddy
than a Buddha buddy and he's Buddha
buddies seek a better body ah so you
introduced them to you I
get 27 essential vitamins and minerals
and an easy source of fiber it has been
said that a man who does not eat enough
fiber May soon find himself trying to
pass a camel through a keyhole
wait in that expression what's the camel
and what's the keyhole so I read
for the monks
environment and they really love that
it's easy and a wallet monks carry
wallets it's a figure of speech and I
will not allow you to damage my calm
grasshopper I must keep the Mind quiet
but I remain in my cheese Zone cheese
Zone I don't think that's a thing
please instruct our viewers to my
that time slash the Y files they'll get
free shipping a heel t-shirt and a get
started guide with their first daughter
ah my sponsor plug
shizo okay the hot and savory Yule is
ready I gotta feed these guys we have
chant practice in 30 minutes and this
group gets Rowdy when the blood sugar
drops
yeah well I thought monks took a vow of
silence don't believe that
believe that she on TV grasshopper you
really have to stop calling me
[Music]
I heard that well you stay on with that
mouth
foreign
in 1966 George Pedley was working his
farm in Tully Queensland Australia when
he heard a strange buzzing sound he
climbed down from his tractor and
started walking in the direction of the
sound then he saw a circular craft
slowly rise above a section of swampland
not 50 feet from where he was standing
the craft hovered for a few seconds shot
straight up into the sky and disappeared
when George went to investigate he found
a large circle of reeds had been pulled
from the swamp and flattened into a disc
the circle was 30 feet across two feet
thick and arranged in a clockwise swirl
because of the swirl and the thickness
of the Reeds locals call the formation a
UFO Nest but what this actually was was
a crop circle
since the 1960s thousands of crop
circles or crop formations have been
found they've been seen on every
continent in almost every country on
Earth but the epicenter for crop
formations is Wiltshire in the southwest
of England
prop formations range from the very
simple
to the very complex
formations can be circles stars and
other geometric shapes but some are
pictograms though nobody knows for sure
they mean
though every formation is different they
have a few things in common recognizable
patterns that are created very quickly
usually at night the creation of these
patterns is always associated with some
kind of light either a beam of light or
an orb of light
whatever that is
[Music]
oh my God
though crop formations seemed like a new
phenomenon there's evidence they've been
appearing for a long time in the 9th
century abigard the bishop of Leon in
France wrote about parishioners who were
possibly engaged in devil worship or
paganism they were collecting seeds out
of flattened circles in the fields and
using them for fertility rituals in 1686
Robert Plott a professor at Oxford wrote
about crop circles even Drew pictures of
a couple that appeared near his home he
said they were formed by a flash of
light and once they were formed animals
wouldn't go near them around the same
time a pamphlet was released called the
mowing devil it describes how a farmer
woke to see a bright light in his field
that he thought was fire when he went to
investigate he found a crop circle it's
called the mowing devil because the
farmer said the circle was so neatly
mowed that it could not have been done
by a mortal man John Leland served as
librarian to Henry VIII he wrote about
patterns appearing in grass overnight in
1937 7 a British science journal
reported circles found in a field of
barley and even included one of the
first photos taken of a crop circle in
1945 this photo was taken by a
balloonist working for the RAF parachute
training school in 1952 the U.S Air
Force investigated circles found in
Kansas in 1963 Sir Patrick Moore an
astronomer writing for the New Scientist
Journal investigated a formation in
Charlton in the wheat Fields with
features taking the form of circular or
elliptical areas in which the wheat had
been flattened one very well defined was
an oval 15 yards long by four and a half
broad there was evidence of spiral
flattening and in one case there was a
circular area in the center in which the
wheat had not been flattened
one of the texts discovered in the Dead
Sea Scrolls is the Book of Enoch Enoch
talks about lightning leading marks on
the earth so these formations have been
seen since the beginning of recorded
history even though thousands of circles
have been found and many people claimed
to witness them forming no one had ever
caught it on camera until 1996.
John Whaley was camping out on a hill
and Wiltshire called Oliver's Castle
named for a fort that was built there
many years ago around 3 AM something
caught his eye he grabbed his video
camera and captured footage of several
glowing orbs hovering over a field then
like magic
whoa
[Music]
here's the formation from the air
nobody can agree on what crop circles
mean though most people believe their
messages now this is frustrating to many
researchers they say whoever's making
these why don't they just speak English
well in 2001 they did
intelligence
[Music]
thank you
see the object came down
[Music]
there's no movement in prevailing wind
all right
this thing is
[Music]
in 1974 the Arecibo message was sent
from Earth to a cluster of stars in the
Hercules constellation it's called the
Arecibo message because that was the
name of the giant radio telescope used
to transmit it the team that created the
message was led by Dr Frank Drake with
assistance from Carl Sagan the message
was 1679 binary digits that could be
converted to an image designed to convey
information about civilization on Earth
it starts with a representation of the
numbers 1 through 10. this provides a
key to the rest of the message next
atomic numbers of hydrogen carbon
nitrogen oxygen and phosphorus which are
used to make up DNA carbon is at the top
because it's the most dominant in forms
of life the message shows more
information about DNA including the
double helix structure for the bottom a
figure of a human its average height and
the population of the Earth which was a
little over 4 billion at the time next
our solar system starting with the sun
and moving out to Pluto the Earth is
shifted up to identify the planet
sending the signal at the bottom a
graphic representing the Arecibo radio
telescope now the nearest star that
could possibly receive the message is 25
000 light years away so we couldn't
really expect a reply for another 50 000
years but on the morning of August 14
2001 a formation was discovered right
next to the chill Bolton radio telescope
that even if you don't know the full
design when you're on the ground you can
tell you're in a crop circle there's
structure and uniformity to it but this
new formation was different it was a
mess it wasn't symmetrical nobody could
make sense of it until it was viewed
from the air
holy
a face and three days later this
appeared
this became known as the Arecibo answer
I Chihuahua the formation uses the same
23 by 73 grid the Top Line shows the
numbers 1 through 10 just like the
original but the reply shows silicon as
the main element for life not carbon
their DNA is shown as having a third
string in the center is a humanoid
figure about four feet tall with a large
head and their population is about 21
billion
below the figure is their solar system
they appear to occupy three objects in
the system the third and fourth planets
and then there is another shape that
could mean a planet or some other object
or structure
on the human Arecibo message is a
picture of the radio telescope which was
used to send the message whoever sent
the reply seems to understand this so
what is this design meant to represent
well just a year earlier this formation
appeared in the same place is this the
same object is this crop formation a
representation of a machine used to
communicate through space again
frustrated researchers and Skeptics
agree on something why don't they just
speak English well almost exactly one
year later this formation appeared
once again we see a face
but that's not a human face
and just like the Arecibo message was
broadcast in binary code the disk
formation also contains binary code and
for the first time we get an actual
literal message the code was translated
to letters using ASCII the encoding
standard for electronic communication
beware the bearers of false gifts
we opposed as a deception
conduit clock
whoever it is that wants to communicate
with us is using many different means in
2004 Robert Ridge was deer hunting a few
miles outside of Roswell New Mexico half
buried in the dirt he found a strange
Rock on the Rock is a geometric carving
Robert grabbed it and didn't think it
was anything more than a cool rock
someone lost at some point but he didn't
keep it a secret he showed it to friends
and anyone who was curious about it it
didn't take long before strange
discoveries were made about the rock for
one its magnetized lodestone which is
not a kind of rock found in that area
and under a microscope the Roswell rock
is extremely smooth there's no carving
marks or indication of sandblasting but
the most fascinating Discovery is that
in 1996 eight years before the Roswell
Rock was found this crop formation
appeared
the designs match up
some people think this design is a
message others think it's a map still
others think the Roswell Rock the
Arecibo answer and all crop circles are
nothing but a hoax but who would create
such elaborate hoaxes and why well in
1991 we would get the answer when a
British newspaper ran a front page story
with the headline The Men Who con the
world oh no
[Music]
laughs
on September 9th 1991 two retirees in
their 60s confessed to starting the crop
circle phenomenon in 1978. Doug Bauer
said the idea came to him one night in a
pub he was living in Queensland in 1966
when the Tully UFO left behind that
Circle of reads Thug thought it would be
fun to trick people into thinking UFOs
were Landing in wheat fields in Southern
England he Enlisted the help of his
friend Dave Chorley all they needed to
make a crop circle was a wood plank a
bit of rope and a twisted piece of wire
at first their designs were simple and
crude but over time they became more and
more complex and you could center this
through this ring walk straight towards
it and lo and behold you've got the
lovely straight line that you could wish
for international media picked up the
story and the Mystery was solved crop
circles were nothing more than a couple
of amiable old fellows playing a prank
and that was that that's it and the
story is kind of disappointing oh we're
just getting started oh go on Doug and
Dave might have created a few crop
circles but their story has a lot of
holes they demonstrated their Circle
making technique and the results were
janky most crop formations even back
then were much more precise Doug and
Dave's formations were out of alignment
every time the more complicated the
design the worse the formations were
during one demonstration for a news crew
Doug attempted to reproduce one of his
circles and accidentally made it twice
as big as it should have been then he
just gave up on making it and their
story changed over time they said they
started making circles in 1976 then it
was 1975 and it was 1978. in fact they
never could agree on the year they
actually started now they claimed to
have created certain circles and then
later said they didn't but they helped
people who did and Doug and Dave said
they created this famous crop circle in
1983 called the cheese foot head Circle
Doug showed a diagram of it but his
diagram had footpaths in it the circle
had no paths it had no disturbances of
any kind when asked how they created the
circle without making tracks in the crop
Doug said they pole vaulted into the
field did you just say Pro vaulted yep
he said in an interview that you should
have seen us running through the fields
with our sticks sailing over the corn I
would like to see that actually oh me
too pal apparently these men in their
60s pole vaulted into Fields carrying
their wood boards they laid down a
perfect crop formation and pole vaulted
out again now Doug looks pretty fit for
an older guy but he's getting winded
walking in a circle pole vaulting seems
a little outside of his athletic range
they also added details to their story
as other crop circles were found one day
a couple of people investigating a
circle told Doug if they were looking
for a jelly-like substance that was
found in a formation Doug told them it
was probably waste ejected from a plane
later Doug had a story about making a
crop circle and while he was doing it he
got hit in the head with a piece of
Frozen waste ejected from a plane's
toilet Eddie kotto's Boeing bombs
he stumbled back to his car dazed with
blood trickling down his face
planes don't dump waste over that area
it would be illegal dangerous and
disgusting another story came out about
people finding bits of metal thought to
be meteorites at crop formations soon
after that Doug and Dave's crop circles
had little bits of iron scattered all
around so a few things did Doug Bauer
and Dave Chorley create some crop
circles yes when Doug and Dave came
forward about 1500 crop circles had been
seen in at least 23 countries
can't pull fall to Belgium right even
Doug couldn't do that but they inspired
a lot of copycats soon most crop
formations were man-made so is there a
scientific way to tell if a crop circle
is not a hoax but genuine
there is
most crop formations are man-made the
vast majority are and there are telltale
signs of this sometimes spotting a
man-made crop circle is as simple as
finding a footpath through the field
leading up to the design but often crop
formations intersect the lines made by
tractors called tram lines which can
hide tracks to spot a hoax we look at
the plants themselves
man-made crop circles done by flattening
plants with boards are destructive to
the plants you'll see cracks and bruises
on the stalks on the ground the crushed
plants look messy the leaves and flowers
will be mashed to the ground marks will
be visible on only one side of the plant
where it was stopped by a plank of wood
many of those marks are creases where
you can actually bend the stalk genuine
crop circles don't look like this at all
first the lay of the pattern will flow
like water there's a gentleness to it an
elegance and many times the stalks are
layered and even braided in genuine crop
circles most plants aren't damaged
they'll continue to grow horizontally
and then after a few days return to
their vertical position in this
formation found in May 2005 the flowers
weren't damaged at all they were somehow
laid down gently
[Music]
a group of clumsy men with wooden boards
couldn't do this we know this because it
was tried a group of crop circle makers
attempted to reproduce this formation
from the air it looks pretty good but on
the ground the man-made version is a
mess the plants are trashed a formation
in 2003 was especially puzzling in parts
of the design the plants weren't
completely flattened they were bent a
few inches from the top it's been
described as like the grooves of a
record how do you make this with planks
and rope you don't you don't another
sign of a genuine Circle can be seen
especially in wheat in late summer when
wheat Turns Gold the kernels become
heavy and bend over from the weight they
also become stiff and are impossible to
straighten but the wheat within a crop
circle the Kernels have straightened out
and can't be bent so what would do this
radiation
wheat stalks are separated by structures
called apical nodes these are like the
knuckles on your fingers in the 1990s
biophysicist William Levin good started
analyzing plants taken from crop circles
his team found the nodes in crop circle
wheat were elongated and in many cases
they were ruptured oh a Rapture on an
elongated node I think they make a cream
for that this rupture is called an
expulsion cavity the only way this could
be replicated is with bursts of
microwave radiation the way your
microwave oven works is it heats up
water fats and sugar in food microwave
energy is heating up the water in the
wheat stock nodes the water turns to
steam and then they burst just like
popcorn now you can't fake this it
happens to the plant internally there's
no way you could hoax that
people who claim to have witnessed crop
circles being made and there's quite a
few Witnesses reports seeing a Mist over
the pattern immediately after it's
formed dismissed is actually steam
coming from the plants that were flash
heated by microwave radiation while
experimenting with radiation leavengood
found prop Circle seed had a huge
increase in growth compared to non-crop
Circle seed by exposing seeds to short
controlled bursts of radiation they grow
bigger and faster than seeds not exposed
to radiation another experiment showed
that wheat harvested from within a crop
circle has a much higher amount of
protein than wheat outside the circle so
there's evidence that whatever energy is
used to create crop formations is
leaving residual traces of this energy
in the area some crop formations are
covered in a dusting of microscopic
spheres of magnetized iron specifically
meteorite iron researchers call this a
magnetic glaze these fears are usually
found around perimeter of a formation
and they're distributed linearly not
randomly because the iron particles are
magnetized perfect spheres it means they
were melted and formed within a highly
energetic magnetic field when people are
inside crop formations many are affected
by electromagnetic radiation
look at this
[Music]
foreign
as part of an experiment a woman with an
enlarged thyroid sat in a crop formation
for two and a half hours while being
monitored by a doctor her thyroid shrunk
by 40
often cameras watches and other
electronic devices stop working inside a
crop circle in fact pregnant women and
people with pacemakers are discouraged
from going near one now to Skeptics all
this talk about energy sounds woo-woo
but I just showed you the real effects
on plants and people now it's fair to
say that the elongated nodes and growth
rates of wheat could be a coincidence
it's also fair to say that the physical
reactions experienced by people could be
psychosomatic all in their minds
Skeptics how do you explain this
these are called ghost formations or
ghost circles this is when the design of
a crop formation is still visible after
the field has been plowed sometimes a
ghost formation remains Through The
Following Season sometimes it remains
for two years before finally fading but
this doesn't happen with all crop
formations nobody knows why but it could
have something to do with where the
patterns are found a study was done in
the early 2000s of all the crop circles
in Southern England found that year the
study showed that 98 of all non-man-made
formations were over chalk aquifers and
by the way chalk aquifers can be used
for generating electricity everything
keeps pointing back to electromagnetism
if there's an epicenter for crop
formations in Southern England it's
silvery Hill silvery Hill was built
thousands of years ago it's 129 feet
tall and covers an area of about five
acres nobody agrees on what it was
originally used for but every year crop
formations appear near it sometimes
right next to it and by the way the
whole thing is one giant pile of chalk
not far from Silver Hill is Stonehenge
crop circles appear there too one of the
most famous of these is called the
Stonehenge surprise on Sunday July 7
1996 this formation appeared near feet
from Stonehenge it's been called one of
the most complex and spectacular crop
circle designs ever seen the design is a
Julius set a type of fractal fractals
are visual representations of mathematic
formulas that repeat themselves at
different scales Zoom way in or way out
the pattern is the same look at how
close Stonehenge is to the formation
look at the visibility Stonehenge has
24-hour security the guards saw nothing
unusual the night before prop formations
also appear near Avery which is in the
same area the Avery hinge is massive
twice the size of Stonehenge now a Ley
line is believed to be an invisible path
or energy line that connects sacred
sites Ley lines are thought to create a
network of energy across the Earth
influencing the flow of energy and
aligning with Cosmic forces the area
around Stonehenge is on one of those Ley
lines if crop formations are an attempt
at communication they're clearly using
mathematic Concepts and this would make
sense math is a universal language but
what do the messages mean What story do
they tell are crop formations proof of
space travel do they offer an
explanation for space travel are crop
formations a map are they blueprints for
a machine well the answer to all those
questions is yes
over the years crop formations got more
and more complex what started out as
simple circles became patterns like this
this is the famous milk Hill Galaxy
spiral found in 2001 the spiral consists
of 409 perfect circles a thousand feet
across spread over 700 000 square feet
and look at how clean the design is
that's not even flat ground this
formation is a hard one for Skeptics to
deal with remember England is pretty far
north in the summer the days are very
very long the night the spiral was made
there was only about four hours of
Darkness it would take a huge crew of
people to lay down this pattern in four
hours and by the way it was raining the
night it appeared you'd think the field
would be full of Muddy Footprints by the
army of hoaxers it would take to make
this but nope the milk Hill spiral is
pristine fractals are a common theme
with crop formations geometric shapes
and other expressions of mathematic
functions are also quite common even
complex math problems are expressed
squaring the circle is a problem in
Geometry first proposed in Greek
mathematics squaring the circle involves
using a compass and a ruler to create a
square and circle with the same area now
this has been proven impossible since
calculating the area of a circle
requires using pi and if you remember
your math lessons Pi is an irrational
number meaning it can never be exact so
you can never get the area of a circle
to equal the area of a square but there
are methods that allow you to get close
and these methods have been seen in crop
formations for years prop formations
often use other mathematic Concepts like
the golden ratio and Fibonacci numbers
here's a formation that when it appeared
people found very confusing did a
mathematician solved it it's a
representation of Pi after 10 decimal
places the lengths of the arcs represent
each digit there's even a decimal point
and an indication that the number
continues forever but there are also
designs that at first glance look like
geometry but not exactly right that's
when some researchers had the idea to
stop looking and start listening this
particular Circle resembles what's
called a cymatic pattern a somatic
pattern is a shape that forms when sound
waves vibrate a material like water or
sand
Ernst clodny was a German physicist and
musician who documented cymatic patterns
he proved that different sound
frequencies create different patterns
and these patterns could be predicted
and repeated could the Builder of this
crop circle be telling us that this
sound frequency has special meaning if
it does how do we apply it well let's
look for more clues in 2011 this double
spiral formation appeared on Windmill
Hill the location of another ancient
site the same day another double spiral
appeared near Stonehenge just a few
miles away Dr Jerry kroth but these
formations could represent neutron stars
and although it's very rare sometimes
neutron stars collide and form a
magnetar
together
what makes magnetars unique is their
incredibly strong magnetic fields which
are among the strongest known in the
universe
these magnetic fields are thousands to
billions of times stronger than those of
neutron stars a magnetar's gravity is so
strong that it dramatically warps
space-time around it in theory this
warping of space-time could lead to an
Einstein Rosen Bridge better known as a
wormhole a wormhole again in theory can
connect two very distant points in space
essentially creating a shortcut that
allows you to travel to a location
faster than light could get there in a
straight line now I'm aware this is a
lot of in theory and possibly and maybe
regarding these crop formations after
all magnetars are so rare that in the
entire galaxy only 10 have ever been
found
well 11.
because the following day literally the
day after these crop formations appeared
a new magnetar appeared I don't mean it
was always there and was just discovered
I mean it wasn't there yesterday and
it's there today then in 2022 this crop
formation appears two sections of
concentric rings connected by a line
it's been theorized that this represents
a wormhole it shows two points in space
surrounded by warped space-time and then
a portal between the outer ring
represents the bending of space-time now
maybe this crop formation is just a
design with no special meaning but that
would be rare almost all crop formations
have a message or purpose so let's
assume for fun that all these messages
are puzzle pieces that when the pieces
are fit together they show proof of a
wormhole and a map of how to get to it
but how how do we do that well that's
the question that electrical engineer
Nicola romanski asked Nicholas saw this
image of a crop circle that seemed to be
meaningless it didn't have a recognized
visible geometry it wasn't symmetrical
but Nicola had an idea he brought the
shape into his 3D software and extruded
it around the center axis meaning he
spun it around to make a shape so Nicola
found more crop formations and did the
same thing he rotated the designs around
a central axis to create their shapes in
3D and after a while he had a collection
of what appeared to be blueprints
instructions on how to create some kind
of machine
what did he do what do you think he
did he built it
Nicola romansky reached out to filmmaker
Charles Maxwell and asked for help
Maxwell was working on a documentary
about prop circles Nicola needed help
and funding to build his machine this
machine he thought was a vehicle that
ran on Zero Point Energy could alter
gravity and reach light speed how can
you not build it so they enlisted 3D
designers and Machinists they hired
electricians and Fabricators it took
over three years and they finally had
their prototype
it didn't work oh well they got some
plasma to ignite but they ran out of
money oh the entire process is in the
documentary which I linked below the
truth is whatever they were building
probably wasn't going to work but it's
possible that Nicola was on to something
that the secret to Zero Point Energy
gravity and space time all comes down to
one thing
spin
whenever government whistleblowers
describe a reverse engineering UFOs spin
is always a core piece of the technology
according to Mark mccandlish a former
Aerospace designer UFO anti-gravity and
propulsion are achieved by rotating
liquid mercury the infamous Nazi
bell-shaped UFO de guaca was said to use
similar technology Bob Lazar talked
about studying Element 115 when he
worked at area 51. e115 is said to power
alien spacecraft and while Czar made
those claims in the 1980s there was no
such element but in 2003 e115 was
discovered a whistleblower came forward
just a few weeks ago he claims to have
been a military contractor working on
reverse engineering UFOs he said their
engines use counter rotating cylinders
with element 115 as the power source
Russian physicist Nikolai kosarev
believed the twisting and spinning of
space-time called torsion was the secret
to unlocking gravity and unlocking
everything in 2019 an engineer working
for the U.S Navy filed a patent for a
plasma compression Fusion device this is
a machine that can generate a tremendous
amount of power like terawatts of power
in a small package the device is about
the size of a car but can put out as
much energy as a nuclear power plant if
it's real the energy is clean and
unlimited his invention is based on spin
the scientist is Salvatore Vice and he
currently works for the U.S space force
he's filed quite a few interesting
patents on behalf of the United States
government propulsion engines room
temperature superconductors inertial
Mass reduction devices and high
frequency gravitational wave generators
this may sound like science fiction but
the US military is taking these patents
very seriously every single one of them
is based on spin now I don't know if
it's irony or poetic justice but it
could turn out that Nature's most
mysterious Secrets like gravity won't be
discovered in a lab it's possible that
unlocking the secrets of nature might be
done in a field of wheat
crop circles are a controversial subject
the history of the crop circle Community
if that's what you want to call it is
filled with Intrigue lies and double
crosses today if you bring up crop
circles in any mainstream venue you'll
get eye rolls and laughter but that
wasn't always the case at one time crop
formations were taken seriously by the
media the government and the general
population a new type of science emerged
called seriology named for series the
goddess of agriculture and grain crops
journals were created articles about
crop formations were mainstream Nick
Pope spent over 20 years investigating
UFOs for the British Ministry of Defense
he said the Army started investigating
crop circles in 1985. then glyphs
started to appear in Southern England in
1989 and crop formations were becoming
complex there seemed to be an
intelligence at work prime minister
Margaret Thatcher asked her cabinet to
find out what the hell was going on the
following summer operation Blackbird was
launched
Blackbird was a three-week surveillance
operation with the goal of filming a
crop circle forming in real time the
project was planned by prominent crop
circle researchers Colin Andrews and Pat
Delgado it was sponsored by the BBC and
Japanese national television not only
did the project have the blessing of the
British government but the crops to be
filmed were on land owned by the
ministry of Defense by working with the
mod Acres of Farmland could be cordoned
off to keep out hoaxers and prevent any
genuine crop circles from being trampled
by a curious and excited public the
military had every inch of the field
covered with cameras they had night
vision and even infrared cameras to
detect body heat if a circle was going
to form it would definitely be seen this
was a huge event millions of people
around the world watched and every day
Colin Andrews would appear on TV and
describe the day's events on day two a
crop circle appeared and Colin Andrews
went on television and spoke very
enthusiastically about the discovery and
then ever everything came crashing down
the formation was a hoax not just a hoax
but an embarrassing one the design was
crude and placed in the center of the
circle was an astrology Board Game Colin
Andrews a serious investigator and the
face of the crop circle phenomenon was
humiliated somebody's had a laugh
they've had a joke they've actually done
none of us any good that sets these sort
of things only set the research back
in the span of an afternoon the field of
crop circle research went from
mainstream science to Fringe Theory and
it's been there ever since hang on but
if the Army had the whole thing blocked
off and covered with cameras how come
they didn't see nothing
it was a setup it was a setup well
allegedly totally a setup Colin Andrews
believes and I think there's plenty of
evidence to support his theory that the
Army intentionally wanted to discredit
him and the entire crop circle
phenomenon that doesn't mean the
military didn't believe in crop
formations quite the opposite at the
same exact time the highly public
operation Blackbird was going on the
Army was running a secret surveillance
operation a few miles away on silvery
Hill in fact they allegedly had film of
bright orbs flying over the fields just
to the south of the hill but this
operation only became known later it
appears that Blackbird was sleight of
hand get the public focused on Blackbird
while the real operation took place a
few miles away even now when crop
circles or glowing orbs appear it's not
uncommon for military helicopters to
show up not only do the helicopters
Patrol the area but they'll also chase
the orbs around the countryside clearly
the military believes that crop
formations are something more than
simple hoaxes but after the Blackbird
Fiasco none of this mattered crop
circles were debunked and Colin Andrews
became a fringe character Colin's
partner pet Delgado was so disheartened
by the Blackbird hoax that he retired
and gave up his research and it sounds
like deep State wins again eh but that's
not the end of the story go on Colin
Andrews may have become Fringe In The
public's eye but he was a serious
investigator and crop circles were a
real phenomenon even without mainstream
support he continued his work and plenty
of people supported him Believers in
crop circles were now Fringe Believers
but they still believed this could be a
problem for the government they couldn't
allow crop circles back into the
mainstream so British intelligence began
a disinformation campaign and to help
them spread disinformation they brought
in the best CIA CIA in his 1999 book
Cosmic top secret the Unseen agenda
author John King got Colin Andrews to
sit for an interview Colin knew that the
only way hoaxers could get onto that
field during Blackbird was if it was an
inside job when Colin made the
announcement that a crop circle appeared
he hadn't even seen it yet it was Pitch
Black he was pressured to make the
announcement so he did he didn't report
what he had seen with his own eyes he
reported what was described to him by
the Army as soon as the sun came up he
knew it was a hoax but there was nothing
he could do he had to deal with the
military that they would provide people
equipment and land but he had to
cooperate with them a big mistake you
shake hands with the military industrial
complex you're making a deal with the
devil yep according to Colin phase one
of the disinformation campaign was to
debunk crop circles with operation
Blackbird phase two was Doug and Dave
who showed up a year later Doug Bauer
and Dave Chorley admitted to being the
makers of crop circles and to this day
that's the official explanation Colin
doesn't think they're part of the
intelligence Community but he believes
they were used by and compensated by
people in the IC they would pay oh yeah
they were paid thousands of dollars for
their story we know this for a fact
because they were only paid half up
front they had to sue for the other half
deal with the devil next came phase
three a freelance journalist named Jim
Schnabel arrived on the scene according
to Colin Andrews Schnabel was CIA now
James Schnabel was not an official CIA
officer but he certainly could have been
an agent if you search his name in the
CIA database you'll get plenty of hits
and schnabel's name is always connected
to Paranormal cases like crop circles
and remote viewing anyway Schnabel was
conducting private interviews with
everyone involved with Blackbird and
with other crop circle researchers he
was driving wedges between people
misquoting them and pushing the
narrative that crop circles were
debunked Colin Andrews became convinced
of schnabel's CIA involvement during a
spooky conversation stable had recorded
and read to Colin the details of private
conversations Colin had one evening
while sitting in his car alone and Colin
Andrews has other evidence that he was
being bugged and surveilled it has to do
a lot with invoices and stuff and I'll
link below if you want the specifics uh
he literally has the receipts he has the
receipts and look it's very very common
for the CIA to use journalists as assets
more common than people think people
talk to journalists so they're useful at
collecting Intel and people listen to
journalists so they're great at
spreading disinformation you may have
heard about operation Mockingbird this
was a project where over 400 American
journalists were working as direct
assets for the CIA call Bernstein
exposed how at least 10 journalists and
editors at the New York Times were CIA
operatives for years and this is still
happening right now and I can prove it
but covering that and operation
Mockingbird is a full episode and if
you'd like to hear the whole story let
me know in the comments now whatever
your favorite newspaper is or your
favorite news channel is assume 10 of
editors reporters and media
personalities are working for the CIA or
FBI in some capacity yes it's that many
well JFK warned us this would happen he
certainly did Colin Andrews remembers a
direct approach from a CIA operative he
met a man who claimed to have seen a
crop circle being formed while he was
out one night studying foxes oh sexy
broads no actual foxes the man used the
story as a way of being accepted in the
crop circle scene people got used to
seeing him around well a few weeks later
this man knocks on Colin's door they go
for a walk and the man asked Colin tons
of questions about crop circles their
locations what he thinks they are and on
and on but Collins started to get
annoyed when the man was asking if he
knew if the Russians were involved at
the end of their talk the man tells
Colin you're one of us now I said what
do you mean
and he said that sounds even funny
coming out of my mouth but he said CIA
the man told Colin that there was a
large amount of money waiting for him in
a Swiss bank account all he had to do
was State publicly that crop circles
were a hoax Colin could go on
researching circles all he wanted the
CIA would help him become the number one
crop circle expert in the world they
would give him special equipment they
would give him a staff they would give
him a budget but when he came across a
real crop formation he was to call this
man and nobody else Colin Andrews passed
on this offer but the man harassed him
with phone calls for a while after that
soon the calls became so threatening but
Colin contacted the British Ministry of
Defense but they said there was nothing
they could do well what well they said
it was out of their jurisdiction oh was
he in England
yep that is a bunch of bulls yeah Colin
was annoyed but after a short time the
call stopped eventually Colin Andrews
moved to the U.S and here he was
approached by a pentagon analyst who
introduced him to a writer named
Rosemary Allan geiling you might know
her name from her many appearances on
the Coast to Coast radio show she wrote
49 books and even hosted her own radio
show all about the Paranormal Colin said
Rosemary went to in his words every
extreme to try and convince him to
co-author a book with her and she wanted
to work on the book in his office which
would give her access to Colin Andrews
entire database on crop circles going
back 30 years she was persistent but he
turned her down Colin is convinced
without a doubt that Rosemary giley was
a CIA asset again Roseberry giley was
the perfect candidate for an
intelligence asset especially since she
was a regular guest on Coast to Coast
where she would be heard by millions of
people she would be allowed to continue
her work in any way she wanted but from
time to time she would be instructed to
disseminate information provided by the
intelligence Community it's more common
than you think so yeah Rosemary giley
was the perfect asset uh I can't help
but notice jira you're speaking about
her in a past tense yeah she died in
2019 at the age of 69. man it's it's
kind of young to die isn't it isn't it
there's another crop circles character
with an interesting story
John Lundberg is an English artist and
documentary filmmaker who founded the
website circlemakers.org in the early
90s he's responsible or claims to be
responsible for some of the more
elaborate crop formations that have been
found over the years on the circle
Maker's website which is still around
there are links to the many crop
formations that the group takes credit
for there's no doubt that the circle
makers created complicated and often
very beautiful crop formations but crop
circle researchers Robert Hulse and
David a Caton think there's more to John
than meets the eye but in our opinion
the the whole circle makers website and
Lumberg and Co are all part of a
disinformation
campaign possibly funded by government
Hall said at one time the circle Maker's
website had a recruiting link that took
you directly to the recruitment page for
MI5 British Military Intelligence host
believes that the circle makers group is
funded by British intelligence and was
specifically created to spread
disinformation pulse believes the circle
Maker's goal is to muddy the waters and
confuse serious crop circle researchers
to make it as difficult as possible to
determine what was and wasn't a genuine
crop formation now there's no hard
evidence that the circle makers or its
founder are connected to Military
Intelligence but in 2009 researcher
Richard D Hall dug into lundberg's
background and found a lot of
interesting information Lundberg got his
masters from the Slade School of Fine
Art in London in 1992. at this time
Slade was next door to the then secret
headquarters of MI5 at 140 Gower Street
it was literally next door the two
buildings shared a courtyard Paul makes
the point that intelligence agencies
often recruit final year college
students that's always been true and is
still true today Lundberg started making
crop circles immediately after
graduating Paul notes that if you view
the HTML source of circlemakers.org the
second keyword is MI5 now that was in
2009 but even today the site's keywords
contain entries like MI5 and CIA and
something I just noticed while
researching this episode why is alleged
CIA asset Jim Schnabel a keyword on this
site in 2004 the circlemaker's website
teased Colin Andrews who at the time was
raising money for his research Circle
Maker said that if the fundraising fails
Colin could just join MI5 psyops and
retrain to be a crop circles Maker Now
psyops is short for psychological
operations which is the use of
psychological techniques and tactics to
influence the perceptions attitudes and
behaviors of a group of people and this
is a type of strategic communication
used by military intelligence and
government organizations all the time it
sure is just turn on the news well
that's true if you spent an hour reading
the news today you consumed government
Intel believe me now Hall acknowledges
that these references to MI5 seem just
too blatant but he believes they're a
Double Bluff meaning if we sarcastically
connect ourselves to the intelligence
Community people will think we're joking
nobody would be so obvious but this is
absolutely a real and effective psyops
technique Paul found that the website
was hosted in Pittsburgh at the time and
even today to some degree it's uncommon
for British organizations to host their
sites in the U.S and Hall found that the
administrative contact for the domain
belongs to a colonel in the U.S Air
Force now it could be a coincidence but
the man has an unusual name now I'm not
going to name him here but I'll link to
Hall's research down below Richard Hall
looked into Circle Maker's finances
tried to figure out how they pay their
bills Lundberg had registered a couple
of companies but they were inactive but
there was an interesting quote on the
circle Maker's website you'd be
surprised how expensive running a
successful website can be Don't Panic
we're not going to ask you for money our
retainer from sources we'd rather not
disclose has kept our virtual head above
water
what does that mean a retainer from who
who's financing them making crop
formations is technically a crime it's
trespassing vandalism destruction of
private property what investor would
fund that and become complicit in those
crimes plus there could be civil
liability if you create a crop circle
and a bunch of strangers show up and
tear up my field I could sue you for
that even if they're minor crimes and
rarely prosecuted it doesn't sound like
a good investment Paul did a land
registry check on the apartment where
Lundberg was living at the time he found
that technically there are no Apartments
listed on the deed Paul dug further and
found that there are four Apartments
including lundbergs that have their
rents paid by the local government so
did Richard Hall reveal that John
Lundberg is in fact an asset working in
media whose job is to spread
disinformation about crop circles well
the evidence Hall provides is purely
circumstantial and coincidental so
there's no way to know for sure in fact
some of Paul's evidence is so
far-fetched I left it out in this
episode but a few years after Richard
Hall conducted his research Lundberg
directed A Documentary a documentary
that I've referred to multiple times on
this channel it's called mirageman
mirageman covers Richard Doty a retired
special agent who worked for OSI the
United States Air Force office of
special investigation Air Force
intelligence Richard Dodie is according
to miragemen one of the chief architects
of the military's campaign to
disseminate lies to the UFO community in
other words to spread disinformation
Dodie's job was to muddy the waters so
UFO researchers wouldn't know what
sightings were real and what were hoaxes
now this is according to Hall Hall's
Caton and many others exactly what the
circle makers have done and have been
doing to the crop circles Community for
years there's a reason why John Lundberg
would make a great intelligence asset
and rosemary giley and James Schnabel
and countless other writers journalists
and media figures they already work in
the Paranormal Community they're trusted
by that community Unity they continue to
do their work but every so often they
spread a little bit of disinformation to
that Community a little nugget to steer
people away from the truth this is why
you shouldn't trust anyone in the media
whether it's your favorite news anchor
TV show host podcast or blogger or
writer be wary of anyone with influence
these media personalities may seem
trustworthy they may seem like they have
your best interests in mind but some of
that is just a performance not all of it
but some of it is a performance designed
to sway your opinion or even alter your
entire belief system the intelligence
Community does not want you to know the
truth about crop circles UFOs secret
space programs or alien technology
that's a fact Millions perhaps billions
of dollars are put into black budget
programs designed to distract and
confuse you from the truth when CIA
needs to spread disinformation they look
for trustworthy people with large
audiences to deliver their message so
keep your eye out for Clues an
intelligent is operative an agent an
asset could be
anyone
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ you know hecklefish
Hi how are you this has been the Y files
if you had fun or learned anything do us
a favor like comment subscribe share
that stuff really helps the channel and
like most topics we cover on this
channel today's topic was recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and special thanks to
our patrons who make all of this
possible you guys are the heart of the
channel and I can't thank you enough for
being so generous if you'd like to join
a great Community consider joining the Y
files Discord it's free to join and it's
a lot of fun but if you'd like to
support the channel maybe become a
member on patreon it's as little as
three bucks a month you get all kinds of
perks and you help keep this crazy train
going or if you'd rather get stuff grab
something from the Wi-Fi store yeah you
better buy these t-shirts uh CIA Grant
is about to expire cute that's gonna do
it until next time be safe be kind and
know that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you